you're watching book tv
next former cia operative robert bear
talks about the history of political
assassinations and his own connection to
them he also discusses what goes into
achieving the perfect kill this is about
an hour fifteen
there's one person in the world who can
say that george clooney won an oscar
playing him
and that would be our guest tonight
robert bear
siriana was adapted from his
best-selling memoirs see no evil and
sleeping with the devil bob is one of
the most accomplished cia operatives in
the agency's history
he has won the career intelligence medal
and speaks eight languages
he spent much of his 21 years with the
cia in the middle east and one of his
most notable assignments of which there
are plenty was attempting to assassinate
saddam hussein
he is currently national security
affairs analyst for cnn and one of the
world's foremost authorities on the
middle east
he takes us on a wild adventure through
the history of assassination in his
latest book the perfect kill
and in thinking about who the perfect
fit would be to interview bob tonight
obviously we needed someone with the
appropriate gravitas and experience and
deep knowledge of complex cia and
political history and clearly we also
needed someone who had been portrayed by
a major movie star in a movie based on
their work
so we are deeply honored to have lowell
bergman here to interview bob
lowell is one of the founders of the
center for investigative reporting at uc
berkeley where he is the riva and david
logan distinguished chair in
investigative journalism he spent 22
years as a producer with abc and cbs and
is currently a correspondent and
producer for pbs's front line and oh
yeah his investigation into the tobacco
industry for 60 minutes was chronicled
in the film the insider and al pacino
played bowl
so please join me in welcoming the men
george clooney and al pacino could only
pretend to be bob bear and lowell
bergman
oh good evening
bob you know before i came here tonight
i
emailed first time i ever heard your
name
was back in the early 1990s
and then one of your supervisors in
washington
said to me we have this maniac out in
the middle east
how did
how did you get into the cia
well you know i think it was um it was
actually berkeley's fault
i was studying chinese
i was going to a graduate program
and i was out of money and sort of
looking for a job part-time my roommate
said
okay good job
you know i can't study chinese forever
so
i thought this was very funny and i said
well maybe the cia and it's like it was
the pike committee and church pike
committee hearings i see oh that'd be
hilarious so i called up the federal
center in san francisco and there was a
long pause
and
i think that the operator thought this
was a joke or something anyhow she found
the number of the cia which was in
lawndale california which is
down in orange county is that orange
county no it's a palm desert i think
it's like it's it's out in the middle of
nowhere
i called them up and they sent me an
application it was like 50 pages long
and only somebody unemployed would feel
would have the time to fill it out
and i said look yeah i was there no way
i was going to get
hired my mother used to teach at ucla a
little red school house in those days
i'd grown up in aspen the only thing i
knew how to do was ski race and barely
got through college and i said
this is not going to work
he called me up one day said let's go
and 21 years later i was still in
all right so
and just to make sure that everybody
understands you say let's go
you were a cia officer right
yeah the i was at what was called a case
officer and when i applied for the job
here they described it to me what an
analyst that he actually
she or he works for the cia it's in
their on their resume they have cards
for it you know everybody knows they go
to academic conferences
and you know they they go to school and
things like that and i told the guy in
this interview that's what i want he
says well without an m.a you can't have
that
but we've got this other job where
people go overseas and they they drive
around at night
pick up agents and they debrief in them
and they steal secrets and they carry
guns and things like that
seriously i i didn't watch james bond
films i mean just and i didn't own a gun
either
i said yeah i'll take it sure if that's
fine you know just you know
i mean i'll i'll do bungee jumping you
know if you say it's a year from now i
say yeah let's go but when it comes time
to go so anyhow
the cia's divided into analysts who are
you know sort of want to be academics
and operatives who go to weird places
like iraq and afghanistan
and collect intelligence or as the fbi
describes the cia is they're the
we can't we catch bank robbers and they
rob banks
so so basically you had a license to
steal
to lie
oh yeah if you ever want to do a
break-in
let me know if we break into banks
um you were expected to lie from the
time you got up in the morning till the
time you went to bed
um you figured your your phone was
tapped and you would just tell these
fantastic stories if you were going out
to the drugstore you were just
completely saying something totally
opposite in the conversation to throw
people off it was just misdirection
your entire life
okay and so you
you go into this though in the wake of
the church committee hearings
the so-called reforms of the 1970s
related to the intelligence community
things that many things which are now by
the boards the national security
uh you know the fisa law and so on
so how did that restrict you at that
time did it in any way
well i think that they had a hard time
getting people to time so that's why
they took me you know it's they um
like i said i came from a liberal family
my mother ran for county commissioner
picken county colorado
and the other half of the ticket was
hunter thompson
if anybody can remember that i mean
she's
she was a socialist and he wanted the
sheriffs to drop mescaline so i mean
don't ask me how the cia missed this but
they did
but they all but they've missed many
things they missed a lot of things like
like when i applied
they sent a security guy around the
neighborhood he had a suit on and a tie
and everything and and i lived with this
in berkeley used to be
fairly liberal at one time
and i had these roommates they were both
anarchists and i was studying chinese
and i had put very cleverly on the wall
a picture of mount seiton and i'd
written in chinese the east wind blows
red
and they had they owned a boa
constrictor there was this knock on the
door i came down and there was i was
home alone and there's this guy said
do you do you know mr barry your
neighbor and i said well that's me and
right then the boa constrictor started
coming out the second floor coming down
it i don't know what he wrote in his
report but
i got your security
i'm just telling you i just don't have
to make sure all of you understood who
we're dealing with
okay so
let me fast forward
to this book because you've had a number
of books okay
when you were in this cia
you couldn't kill anybody could you you
couldn't assassinate no you could not
assassinate when you came in
um you had to sign an agreement that you
had read and understood the meaning of
executive order one two three three
which is you can't kill anybody as a cia
officer
it's against the law you go directly to
jail
and if you talk to anybody who proposed
murder
you had to break off contact it was it
was clear cut
and you know you know you go back in the
40s and the 50s and you see these
well you had the castro stuff of course
but that never really got off the ground
i mean you know 61 the bay of pigs that
was over but that was never very serious
going to the mob and we sort of held
that out the whole assassination thing a
castro is just a really dumb idea and
we're never going to do it again and
every officer whether they were analysts
or operatives had to sign this order and
they were very serious about it
so
in your 21 years you
and we'll get to the saddam incident and
and uh and mugney or
radwan and your your obsession with him
in a minute but in your 21 years you
never got to kill anybody is that right
no i did not with your hands i never
killed anybody i never threw a grenade
into a school bus i never
um i was issued pistols but didn't like
it i'd keep the magazines out i was
always afraid i was going to shoot
myself on the foot
they gave us machine guns and mortars
and all this stuff and a lot of training
military training jumping out of
airplanes but it was more like hey guys
this is what it's all about so when you
talk to people you you have familiarity
with guns
but it was you were never
gonna go out and shoot anybody i mean it
just if you even talked about shooting
anybody they'd run you out
and
how do you wind up going to lebanon
because that becomes your obsession at
least for a decade or more
i studied arabic
and i worked in a consulate in studied
arabic for two years
and i worked in a consulate in the
middle east interviewing people for
visas
um which solidified arabic needless to
say so after four years in this
assignment
lebanon had that point had gone to hell
in the sense that our chief of station
had been kidnapped
uh the embassy had blown up been blown
up in in april 83 the marines in october
second embassy in 84.
and they had a list of one of people who
spoke arabic and would go to beirut that
was me
in fact
yeah just me i was walking down the hall
i was in africa division at the time
don't don't ask me why i got thrown out
of the near east division but i did so i
was walking down and they said don't you
speak arabic yeah do you wanna go to
europe do you wanna go to beirut i said
yeah let's go and so
it was like another prank like joining
the cia
i'll tell you when you win it was it was
it got your attention because you took a
helicopter from cyprus it was a
blackhawk and there were two of them
it come out
and it was i the whole idea of commuting
in a helicopter was all a bit strange
but when it got to beirut the helicopter
dropped down about 10 to 15 feet off the
off the ocean floor so he was spraying
and the guys you know get their 50
caliber machine guns in the doors put
their flak vests on cia's didn't get
flak vests and they they come in and
they're going right to the right into
shore and this thing turns on its side
these guys were from delta force the
pilots flipped over hills and landed and
they said you've got you know i you know
10 seconds to get out of the helicopter
and all your stuff otherwise going to
push you out and then you were there in
beirut the place was burning and there
was shelling going everywhere it was
like it's like apocalypse now
and
so what do you discover
you're supposed to be you're supposed to
be hunting who did the embassy right
i was sent there mainly to look for the
hostages because they had completely
disappeared you know this is bill
buckley ap reporter we go right where a
guy from aub american university of
beirut
uh they had disappeared and at that bill
buckley was the chief of the chief of
station yeah the top cia officer not
only in baby and i mean when they've he
completely disappeared he was hit over
the head at this apartment coming out
thrown in the back of a car disappeared
in the southern suburbs and we
completely lost trace of him
you also had the question of the embassy
in april
83 which was blown up by a gmc pickup
truck
that managed to get in
underneath the portico and exploded and
it was the first suicide bombing against
the united states which was a huge
mystery to us
at the time
um
it mystified that the fbi the guys who
had made the explosives actually wrapped
him around the firing device so there
was no
there was no signature on the bomb which
was a
huge always signatures on bombs there
was none on that
the truck had been stolen the suicide
bomber we couldn't identify
even it was such a thorough explosion
that there was no traces on the wall and
this was clearly
of such professionalism that nobody in
the united states government had ever
seen this period so that you're you're
you're presenting me that with this
mystery to try to solve who blew up our
embassy
and they blew up the french
barracks the french barracks in october
along with the marines
i believe that they were involved in
locker b pan am 103 same people they
were clearly at a level way beyond bin
laden or isis in terms of communications
they didn't have any communications they
so at this point
the shia
either hezbollah or the iranians
were killing more americans than any
other terrorist group in history right
barring none 200 and what was it um 71
61 at the marine barracks
if you don't remember this they took a
step fan and they drove it right through
the guards and up the steps and into the
barracks
it caused reagan to pull out of lebanon
uh the biggest loss of marines since
world war ii in a single day
i mean this i i until this day i've i've
never seen professionalism like this in
a group
and you were a secret weapon on the
ground i was it
the the failed ski racer from aspen
colorado
is gonna it's gonna solve this yeah so
what did you do
i you had to figure out lebanon which
meant working and this this is i wasn't
serious about anything to like until i
got to this one
this big question
and that was to use intercepts
uh reading hundreds and hundreds of them
a day
because in lebanon with the phones gone
they were using
low power communications
and it's sort of a basin in beirut and
these you can pick these up
you have a site
and it was very complicated they write
this stuff out it was just simply
we called them matrices at the time
today they call them algorithms and it's
all done by computers but at the time
i had
stacks of stacks events on my office of
these of these intercepts
and in the process you started to zero
in on
basically the perfect killer the man
behind you his name is imad magnia
he's lebanese born 62
he had trained with fata
he had gone to the battlefront when he
was about 15. um
took a year off to study business
affairs for aub don't ask me why um
and then in 1982 he was
recruited by iran by the islamic
revolutionary guard corps
and put on the front line and assigned
to start
killing americans
he was you know you know he was remember
the explosions in argentina he was
clearly involved in that that's not
until 90s yeah
this is a continuous shedding american
blood for 20 years
this is the israeli embassy in the
jewish communities yeah in in argentina
and he set off bombs in paris in 85
remember those the department stores
he set one off in london
i mean he's there was there was nobody
like him
a period i mean in terms of
simple capabilities of his ability to
disappear and stay off telephones and
talk about misdirection
the guy was he just he was simply
brilliant at what he did
so he's the guy
in a sense he's your white whale in this
book he's the guy you're hunting oh he's
absolutely the white whale yeah
this this is the guy
that i wanted bad and don't ask me when
that that switch flipped now what we had
on the guy
was a sealed arrest warrant
and it was from the department of
justice
and we were if we ever got in the
position to arrest him we were supposed
to notify the marshals and the fbi and
the rest of it and go through a whole
procedure
i mean a guy like this is obviously not
going to be arrested by the marshals or
the fbi and they're not going to come to
beirut and the lebanese police
aren't going to arrest him i mean he had
his own passport
filed stolen from the police all of his
records he had all of his records that
he'd ever gone out of beirut airport
erased from the hard drives and physical
records
so
at that point i sat down with the
ambassador john kelly the chief of
station and a guy named chuck mckee a
couple other people and said
look we could get close to this guy but
he's he's going to resist he's going to
probably die
and the ambassador said well that's a
hypothetical you know don't deal with i
don't deal with hypotheticals when you
get to that point to arrest him
but for me that was
open season on the guy
hypotheticals
hypothetically there was no longer an
executive order one two three three
well when we get to iraq i mean it's if
if somebody's resisting arrest and this
is this is how bin laden was killed he
was considered enemy combatant and
dangerous
and shoot him i mean it's it's lawyers
it's definitions you know
i mean really i mean it it it's against
the law to assassinate people
but if you
describe the situation
as a war zone you can do it anywhere
um
you can kill somebody
if i could just have a small footnote
here i had a conversation with the seal
from seal team six and he's out
and i was living in berkeley at the time
and i said tell me about your
authorities
and he said well listen if we get a pid
on somebody
um
what's a pid it's a positive
identification we can go in them unless
there's total submission
and that's like you're on the ground
without your clothes off everything and
you're you have no threat to anybody at
all
they can't shoot you but it's short of
that they can shoot you i see looks i'm
living in berkeley at the time and i
said if i'm in berkeley and you get a
pid can seal team six come through the
windows and kill me yep including on u.s
soil
now of course the context for that is if
the united states lost control of part
of the country in some
conflict but if you take that idea as
well as much as i understand it and i
didn't go to law school
you can apply it to yemen aolaki the
american imam that was killed
bin laden
the seal team six is very capable could
clearly grab that guy alive um
but in your book the way that you
describe mugna or hajwa
radman right red one
um
you describe him as being
focused he knows his enemy he knows what
he's going to accomplish in this
particular action that he's going to do
he has a political objective of some
kind that's limited
he doesn't waste energy he doesn't waste
time he has a follow-up operation i mean
it
it's almost uh
a love
poem to him in the sense of seeing an
expert do what he does
but you say the exactly the opposite
about what we're doing
i mean
well i mean i i
i i'm a contrarian and i don't like
american foreign policy i think we
assassinated bin laden in 2011 and we
have something a lot worse
in isis than all baghdadi because we
will not acknowledge that we are dealing
with an insurgency a sunni insurgency
and assassination isn't going to do any
good at all
i mean
we've taken political murder to the
middle east
hoping it's a detour around war or at
least shorten war but it's it's not what
we've got because in iraq we are going
into
what i think is going to be 100 years
war
i mean i just i just you know i don't i
don't see any sense in playing the air
force to iran in iraq and that's what
we're doing we are they are selecting
the targets and we are hitting them with
the air force and drones it's just not
going to work but if you take
lebanese context in 1999 hajj radwan
was trying to force the israelis out of
lebanon to leave there they had a
security
and what he did was
in a very
technically brilliant operation
hit the israeli commander with a with a
shaped charge
he was traveling at high speed and and
hit him directly in the door
and
the israelis pulled out in less than a
year saying this enemy is too capable we
are better off pulling our forces back
defending israel
proper rather than staying 11 on the
security the security zone which which
magnia was hitting them hard it's it's
too expensive
and will simply hit them with mass force
which they did in 2006 which worked so
what he did because assassination
the purpose is to preserve force and
avoid war
but if you're assassinating people and
it's getting you deeper into war
you're going against the whole intent of
it
and this this is the argument i make we
simply cannot project american power
around the world using political murder
if we were
confined to a space like lebanon where
there's only four million people
and when when mugna
hajradwan killed people it was with a
very specific purpose in his
intelligence
was it was perfect he was listening to
phones and the rest of it
and then but then i go in farther into
the story because i worked for the
united nations on an assassination
investigation and that was the prime
minister who was killed in 2005.
and what what had mognia did kill him
with a car bomb and and you know 20
other people
he had gone from taking this as a tactic
to to avoid war
to a sectarian conflict and killed a man
who
was a symbolic head of the sunni in
lebanon and it's only got them more
violence it'll get them more so he broke
all his rules he started to break him he
did very well for about 20 years
um
and he made other mistakes too like he
he remarried
and moved to damascus and started using
a cell phone
and kept a certain house you know he
lived in a certain house and he then set
himself up as a target and he was
assassinated in 2008
but
are you saying that for 20 years or
until he was assassinated in 2008 and
we'll get to the assassination in a
minute
he managed to avoid the nsa the cia
all of our military intelligence people
sealed team six and and mossad and most
i dearly wanted to kill him
and they know what they're doing they
were after him they killed his brother
he
he completely disappeared he used to
ride a motor scooter and pretend to be a
tailor or a butcher or something like
that
completely he was unknown even in
hezbollah which nominally he was under
that umbrella he was unknown people know
who he was
maybe three or four people did no
defectors nobody that could be turned
never had a defector from mugna's side
we had one from other hostage takers
we've had them from the iranians
but never in his group was there anybody
came out
that
you know that betrayed him no
and what do you account how do you
account for that i mean
you were in your book you say you were
worried at one point that you were going
to get hit by him
oh i think i think definitely they were
they were looking at us i mean the
problem is i grew up middle class and i
didn't grow up in a war zone i mean you
take people who have been in a civil war
and and
their families are getting killed and
they're killing people
they tend to figure out what they're
doing and it's the darwin effect
i mean when i talk about you know the
the admiration is for his skill
but i certainly wouldn't trade my life
for his growing up in the southern
suburbs
and
of beirut and
you know as a teenager
leaving school with a kaleshnikov and
going shooting at the other side
i mean
this part of the world that's falling
off
you know
you know you know progress and and and
sort of any
anything we take as civilization is
growing by the day i mean you look at
mali
you look at nigeria with boko haram you
look at
it isis which is which is truly
pre-islamic i mean this cutting off
heads
with knives is tribal
or or or kidnapping women this is tribe
but it's nothing to do with islam
so
this world the world of magnias the
ability to murder people
for political ends
there are more and more people that are
capable of doing this and it was my
interest in
in in in
because this is part memoir i mean i i
write my mother into the story she was a
great i was gonna ask you what is your
mother doing in the middle of lebanon
well she was a great character assassin
so
and she i mean she clears she should
have had my job but but that's beside
the point but so i mean i want to make
it personal how far i am from this world
and even how far the cia is yes we can
we can put drones up and we can
sit in front of a flat panel screen and
kill people but it's it's
this this is not our world
well you write that that the best
assassins or the best kills are local
what do you mean by that
well the best kills are inside the
family i mean you know who the cancer is
you know who the problem is in removing
them it's it's
it is local i mean take one of the great
assassinations of this historically
determined assassination that was rabin
in 1995.
i think if anybody could have
you know cut to the chase on a on a
on a middle east settlement was him i
mean he was a hero
he was well respected
um
but if you take the point of his enemies
removing him
truly made a difference but that was
very local it's kind of politics i don't
understand but for them it made sense
and of course then i go back to the idea
of of killing hitler i mean clearly that
would have saved lives
and avoided destruction untold
especially if it'd been done in 33
there are occasionally figures
uh in history
which are cancerous
and they should be cut out i mean the
whole idea we hate assassination as
americans we just hate the idea we hate
to admit we do it but we do it we've
done it to lincoln we've done it to
mckinley we've done it to more
the most dangerous job in the world
actuarially as president of the united
states yeah exactly but that's why we
hate it so much we think of kennedy we
think of lincoln and it's it's lunatics
and the rest of it but what we're
missing
is
the ability to change history at a
particular moment in a particular
context
it does save lives
and i think where the reason i wrote
this book is
is to examine this modern modern
assassination i talk about laws in here
very briefly of an academic from
university of minnesota went out there
and
found out that at a certain point in
laotian history there were political
assassinations i mean
that the local communities and the laos
are not violent people
they felt for the community community
survival they had to kill certain people
and they did and
he found that it was
it was a successful the most successful
possible route to conflict resolution
that's something we don't want to admit
no it reminds me we had a local assassin
here in the san francisco area a man
named james the weasel fratiano who was
a mafia guy and eventually he became a
semi-celebrity wrote a book he flipped
over and became a government witness
and i had the
experience of having been sued by him
but then later interviewed him uh at
least he didn't kill you huh at least he
didn't kill you he told me that we only
kill each other okay right and uh and
you know he never killed anybody who
didn't deserve it
well you know no that's it's fine but at
the heart of assassination it has to be
a just act i mean it has to be i and i
think not only
for the assassin it has to be appeared
it can't be it can't be you know you
can't be making money off this or things
like that you you it has to be a an act
of justice and even the victim's side
has got to look at it saying yeah and we
know why you did it the guy was really
bad preserve the community or the
organization and discipline
you know once i got deeper into this i
started talking to crazier and crazier
people and some were biologists and they
said well you know in cell biology
there's a thing and if correct me if i'm
wrong it's a apoptosis where the cells
will
will kill another cell it's cancerous
and so
mcnea or
escaped you
is the reason you wrote this book to
to detail all of your nightmares about
him and all and and try to figure it out
well lol it's it's engagement i mean i'm
the i'm the i think me and my team are
the first americans that have ever
brought up and been in charge of
assassination of a world leader
by the department of justice and the fbi
so for me it's which i'm actually in the
middle of something i start to
understand it i can get engaged i can
think about it and i say this again
well i was in iraq in in 1995
and we had another with ahmed
yeah with ahmed chalabi but he wasn't
part of it and the general came to me
and said listen i represent five
officers in baghdad general officers and
we would like to get rid of saddam
lift the sanctions
would you support a coup d'etat
and
i said sounds good to me i was the cia
chief in iraq
sat down wrote it up sent it back on a
tax set which is classified
and
it didn't get an answer and eventually
they came to me and said well saddam is
going to go to his palace at asia and
we've got we've suborn 12 tanks and
we've got the tank shells for them and
what we're going to do is once you get
in the palaces we're going to ask him to
step down or we're going to kill him
with the tanks and i said well you know
is a tank's main gun
an assassination weapon i obviously
didn't know that so
i sent a message back to washington
saying you know this is their plan are
we okay are we in good ground you know
i never got an answer
this action went forward it was it was
unstoppable at that point
and some of the militias i was working
with overran
three iraqi divisions
and it was quite messy the whole
engagement
and then then i got a message
from washington
saying if you have a criminal lawyer
don't talk to him come right home trust
us on this
uh there's there's been a problem so we
come back badged by the fbi
um have you ever had your office yellow
taped by the fbi it's interesting
um
and i said we're hauling you in for the
attempted murder of saddam hussein
eventually got through this
investigation
but i mean even though
we never actually pulled the trigger on
saddam
it gave me an insight in the way the
thinking the lawyers
what it's like in the field how hard it
is
to target somebody like saddam
just as it would be al baghdadi today
somebody on the move no communications
you don't have eyes on the rest of it so
this is this this is an examination of
assassination and it's it's sort of a
it's a funny title but the perfect kill
is nearly impossible
it's a black swan event
but what you do talk about is the use of
indiscriminate violence whether it's
drones or cruise missiles or
by the us
as as a tactic that's only going to
backfire that isn't going to succeed in
the end
well absolutely i mean low we're doing
what's called signature strikes
and that you have a drone flying above
and they see a couple of guys with
kalashnikovs
you know doing exercises in the field
and
somebody back in washington says well
you know they're near this village
uh this doesn't look right to us we
haven't had a drone strike in a month
let's drop one you know it's the
mountains of yemen or or pakistan
and you look at some years we we've
we'll have a you know
750 drone strikes and not a single name
will ever appear of who we know it is i
mean that it's amazing
or in cars or
and we've overused
we've overused it
we've we've
the whole point of political murder is
to make it very precise i mean you you
really scare the enemy
when you get to the one guy who's
causing you a problem rather than
you know somebody who appears to be
legal i noticed the difference in in
november of 2002 i was doing a story
about the lackawanna six i don't know if
you remember their the so-called terror
sleeper cell in lackawanna new york and
they were recruited by a guy named kamal
derwish who
uh went
had lived in saudi arabia for a long
time but was an american citizen and in
november of 2002
a drone
fired a missile at a vehicle in yemen
and blew the car up and he was in the
car he was the first american citizen
killed in the territory
and at that time the u.s government
backed off of the whole thing oh he was
collateral damage we didn't mean to do
it
he was in the wrong car at the wrong
time today
we take credit for it
well i don't think there's any outrage i
mean
it's so complicated
pakistan and yemen and and now syria and
iraq
that people are just jaded you know they
don't just don't care you know
they don't care about the legal
authorities they don't care about the
accuracy of drones
it's just like they don't care about
enhanced interrogations i mean
i mean you know frankly i've been i've
been keeping track of this and this this
is an aside but
the senate has got 6 000 documents that
say it doesn't work and you got a few
people involved in torture who say it
does
and my feeling is i want to see those 6
000 documents i mean i want to make up
my mind as an american
whether torture
makes us safer or not i mean that
doesn't that doesn't justify it morally
but i'd like to know
but we still don't know i mean there's
there's two sides to this i can't
imagine that the senate would just
you know come to these conclusions that
torture doesn't work
you know because they want to you know
it's i mean i think they're they're
basing it on evidence
so and the war on terror is
i mean it's gone everything i mean it's
in somalia it's in
you know in in africa and you know who
knows where it's going to go next
anywhere where there's blank spots on
the map we can carry war
um
but do we really stop to see what what
it's getting us i mean
i i don't know
has there been a in your in your
experience because i remember
and remember some of your bosses i
remember also fbi people who came in
the fbi in the mid 70s or back then
and
they learned in in a sense about what
could go wrong from the church committee
hearings from the pike committee
hearings
and there was a a sense that we've got
to be more focused we've got to be
smarter about what we do
have we lost that caution have we are
those lessons no longer alive inside the
intelligence community
i think we've lost them i mean
when i joined the cia it was very simple
it was moscow was the problem
you had to recruit a russian military
officer to tell you
when they were going to send armored
divisions through the folder gap
it was that simple
but once it got into terrorism
of course after 9 11 it became very
complicated but for me
what was more complicated
that's made things a lot worse is that
where in the middle east has gotten so
um dangerous that everybody's sort of
locked up in a bubble in the in the you
know hotel in in kabul or
the green zone and
we're looking at the world
through drones and i'm not sure you can
understand it just looking at drones so
what what happened to the cia
after i left was it became a killing
machine
and that's that's what people do
and now they're doing in syria and iraq
and i don't think they do it
particularly well i think you're missing
a lot of the nuances
the whole attack on mosul on isis in
june was apparently missed
president called it the jv team
you know he was misled it wasn't his
fault
but the president who's
was a constitutional law scholar or so
he taught that at law school
he's approved all these things
well i can offer you my political
opinion i mean i think you have you have
a president who's a was fairly liberal
democrat has to cauterize the right
i mean he has to take actions that he
went beyond bush i mean he's increased
in drone strikes
he went after leaks he's gone after
ryzen the new york times which even bush
wouldn't wouldn't do simply to
send the message that i don't i don't
play around with national security and i
think this is what a lot of the drone
strikes are is simply his
um
trying to be strong without sending
american troops back to the middle east
so it's a bloodless way of saying you're
a tough guy americans don't care
do we do you rarely see anything on
you know
people going in and taking pictures
where drones hit or or keeping track of
this
uh it just i'm not talking about
you know i'm talking about the you know
between san francisco
and new york there's a big part of the
united states it just assumes we got to
be doing this they don't they don't look
very
very deep into that
i mean i want to get back to the notion
of assassination it seems to me
assassination is part has been part of
american history
it's yeah but you're looking at the
psychopaths i mean you're looking at
kennedy you're looking at
john wilkes booth john wilkes booth i
mean clearly assassinating lincoln at
that time wasn't going to do the south
any good it was an act of revenge
but but
all these assassinations i think we can
just dismiss as simple criminal acts
and not carried out by a coherent
political organization with a real plan
and so
our assassinations have no plan
but our enemy is focused is that is that
the lesson you're telling us yeah let's
go back to hajj redwan
1989 the syrians in the united states
agreed on
a new president
uh they were going to close down his you
know what was his ball at the time they
were going to civilize lebanon and and
more or less slow down or stop the war
against israel in the south
and mugna
was 17 days after the president was
nominated
set up an operation where he put
explosives and a shape charge
in a closed down candy store and the
president's convoy was going by
and and hit it killed the president cut
his car and half lebanese president cut
his car in half
that was the end of any talk about
closing his ball down or any talk of
restoring the lebanese state
magnia did not have a grievance against
that president
but they felt that they in their
interests were talking about their
interests not ours
felt that they had to cut off they had
to get rid of this man because he was a
danger to what they were doing and that
was the islamic resistance in the south
he he he did have a plan and they and
they and they they followed this plan
consistently and once
they had committed violence they didn't
go on to commit more symbolic violence
and they avoided things like car bombs
which in lebanon as you know everybody
was using them they went out of their
way never to use one in in in built up
areas
and
what they were doing was sending a
message to their enemies that we can use
violence responsibly
and then when we get what we want we
will hold to the agreement
mcnea did it with the french in 85 and
86.
he had a simple message i'm going to
kill you and kidnap you until you stop
supplying weapons to iraq
and that's exactly what happened and
after the french
shirak made that agreement
magnia stopped killing frenchmen
which is something you don't see from
al-qaeda or
or isis who two just ten tend to
slaughter so the french felt that they
were they were they they had a rational
player at the other end
so you're saying that he was a master of
using political violence to get a
political act to get a political end and
then once he got that in he stopped
so you and your friends in in lebanon
decided you wanted to take him out
sure what was so difficult
you've got the nsa you've got
money to bribe people you've got
allies in the christian side of town and
probably allies in the
sunni side of town because he's a shia
we went to our allies the christians and
they said are you out of your mind
they were terrified of him he could
operate in the
west the sunni
wanted to have no part of it
he stayed off any sort of communications
moved from night to night
he completely disappeared into the
southern suburbs which he could do that
was what we call the denied area and we
you know it's we could we used to send
cars through it i remember the area
there was like no there was off the grid
completely but it had its own grid up in
the air of electrical wires and iranian
generators on corners painted with the
iranian flag on it
and nobody would go down nobody would
the army the syrians were scared i mean
ghazi kanan the intel chief the syrians
i mean he's a fairly powerful guy in
lebanon refused to set foot in the
suburbs the southern suburbs and they
were scared of them
um
i mean but that's the whole point of the
book is that you know
we were not qualified to do this and he
was qualified to come after us
if he'd paid me any attention at all he
could have easily found me and got rid
of me
but he probably didn't think it was
worth uh worth the bullet
your name wasn't written on one of his
bullets no my name was not on one of his
bullets and he did we weren't a threat
he had closed the americans down got rid
of the marines
closed the embassy down it was a bubble
uh the central intelligence agency was
not a threat to him well he killed
everybody he was an expert
in the area
yeah he killed in the embassy at buckley
and he um
in the embassy he blew up the embassy
and killed six cia people
but i mean it was it was it was it
was he at that in the embassy bombing i
think was going after phil habib was the
ambassador then because phil habib was
trying to make a peace between israel
and lebanon
and he opposed that clearly just like he
killed the president
it's um
but but again let's go back it was a
very small area
with very narrow grievances and
everybody knew who everybody was and it
wasn't some grand strategy
when he did move to bigger targets and
he was involved in
cobar barracks in saudi arabia in 1996
which is a bomb that went off near the
barracks
killed two dozen american soldiers
um
it was a wasted gesture he also tried to
kill the emir kuwait
and his with his brother-in-law and and
that that failed
so he he looked at these this ability to
project political violence
a long way away and it doesn't really
work and he withdrew and came back
he would he would continually learn
about
what worked and what didn't
and so what's the
i don't want to give away the end of
your book but what's the lesson of all
this
i mean that he could do this and survive
until he was apparently assassinated in
2008 right
that he could survive so long
which is absolute utter discipline i
mean you you
we have found the same thing with our
special operators uh the delta force and
and the seals i mean when they first
went into afghanistan you had um the
loot trail book you know
with it with a helicopter went down it
lost a bunch of guys
we learned our special operators learn
how to fight wars and they're very good
at what they do
um they change tactics for instance in
iraq where they come into a house
it used to be called it
i'll give you a technical term a dynamic
entry and that was hostage rescue and
then they got ambushed one time and they
said we're going to do combat entry and
that's basically shooting but it moves
in the house because we learned how to
fight wars
and
you know we are
they still haven't you know gotten to
his ability to do this
well they did in the sense that when he
went down in 2008 but i won't talk about
that now
so
you know i i'm not you know getting to
the morality of it i don't touch
morality and i'm looking i'm looking at
human nature i'm looking at a bunch of
assassinations
and explain why they worked or they
didn't work and
this is very much a political science
book but what i did was
when i first wrote it there was 21 laws
and they're pretty snappy is
i didn't want to write an anthology it
would be fairly boring so i i wrote
through this narrative of
trying and failing to kill mugna
and then i had to throw some stories
about my mother in which it's like light
lightens it up i don't know if it
lightens it up or well
leaving the restaurant
but
it's 21 lessons
for something that
you say in the end you don't believe it
it's 21 conditions
that you have to meet before you can
hope to carry off a successful political
murder
but if you read each one carefully
they get harder and harder and harder
like don't ever miss
and you know it sounds funny don't miss
but
you know when
when they tried to kill henry v
and they failed he just became a
stronger king it was considered some
sort of divine ordinance that he was
that he was chosen and he became a
stronger you know he invaded france and
took normandy and calais and the rest of
it um
same way you just simply can't afford
and i get into the ira attempt to market
thatcher
when they put a lot of explosives in in
a room and there was no chance of ever
killing her because it was so far away
and the ira at the end of it i don't
think it got anything out of it i mean
if things would have been different if
they had killed the british prime
minister
but the ones that work
i
call it terror if you like but
a capable assassin is clearly more
uh you know
something you got to worry about and you
better change your behavior as opposed
to a bumbling assassin i mean that's an
obvious rule um
not not leaving
your fingerprints on an assassination is
also scary i mean like blowing up the
the embassy in april 1983
it certainly scared the fbi and the cia
when they saw this complete explosion
you know destroyed the firing device i
mean we knew
what we were up against and as opposed
to
bin laden who you know goes on tv and
was locked up in a house in the bada bot
al-qaeda doesn't really exist now it was
it's not a formidable organization it's
turned into something worse
but
he clearly wasn't as capable as
you say it's not a but it's not a
formidable organization but the pentagon
would tell you that's because we've our
drones have taken their leadership out
in the in the northwest territories and
we've tracked them down look al qaeda
was a pickup operation
and and i'm just reflecting what people
tell me that have followed this from the
beginning inside the government
otta hamburg puts this together
uh gets some money a little bit money
from from bin laden al-qaeda shows up
says hey we're going to do this and
he says yeah fine go do it
they got very lucky um
is the pentagon told me over and over
again that that
our paradigm changed on 911 with flight
93 that no you can't give up the
cockpits there are people willing to
kill themselves so in in a sense we had
made a major that the the passengers had
on flight 93
once they heard about the the world
trade center
so that changed and i i don't i don't
think you can look at isis as an
existential threat i mean it terrifies
me that they're going to set off an
explosion in this country and kill a
bunch of people it won't only be a
tragedy but it will be an incentive to
go into more wars in the middle east
which we ultimately can't win
and and i think the really the problem
with with sunni violence in the middle
east it is so indiscriminate killing
journalists
setting car bombs off in baghdad
the world trade center um i think this
is
it this is a very aggrieved damaged
religious sect
whose survival is at stake
here
and you have a fringe that is lashing
out with this extreme violence which
with mugna
he had
wanted everybody out of his country as
opposed to
you know changing the american way of
life or striking out at us i mean
i think he could have done set off a
bomb in new york or chicago and
we trace groups he just didn't want to
it was the narrow channeling of violence
is much more
efficient
and people are ready to go on because
what do we do with lebanon we just got
up and left
we know we bombed it in 84 in the spring
a little bit and then we just left i
mean
no real damage imagine a battleship new
jersey going yeah i was in the back car
at the time they never never never hit
anything
um you can that's the shells are the
size of volkswagens you know and they
just you'd sit in the back con you'd
hear them fly over and explode and
the lebanese were convinced we were
firing blanks you know but it it didn't
deter anybody
and so
baghdadi
the leader of the islamic state
apparently was just wounded right yeah
is that going to make any difference no
no he's
um
we tend not to listen to our enemies
which is always a big mistake i listen
to his sermon in mosul and he's very
uh he's arabic is just riveting i mean
it's a very beautiful arabic and
he didn't sound crazy um
but you have to look at baghdadi and ice
and isil or isis or whatever we're
calling it is a manifestation of these
grievances of people in that area you
know when you have that much chaos
the default is to some purified
imaginary point in history which these
people
are trying to return to
so we could kill baghdadi today he could
have died on saturday and and there
wouldn't be any change really
um
you would have somebody he'd be replaced
and the british chief of staff even said
this he went on tv on sunday morning and
said hey guys we can get rid of him it's
not going to do us any good
so a
political murder is not going to work
there you know if
the islamic
state were on the run and were falling
apart and you could get rid of its
leadership
it would speed it up
but right now it's here to stay
with that i think
i'm told i should open up for questions
are there questions in the audience
this question is on your left
thank you both um i'm curious mr bear
what your mother knew about your
profession and what you thought about it
she was living in venice california at
the time and she said if you tell
anybody you work for the cia i'll cut
your throat
she was very liberal and now she just
didn't she was not amused there are
liberals in the c.i.a
they're a bunch of them that's why i
tell it didn't matter it's just like
i've got you know i have my my friends
don't ever say it
don't ever
um
my daughters didn't know until i went on
60 minutes
and they were sitting there watching tv
and said uh oh dad's on tv
that was with rich bonin
next question is also on your left
um what would you propose we do with
isil or not do anything at all i mean
what what's your thoughts on that
well i'm sort of involved this in the
sense i keep up with the tribes in anbar
province
and
they are quite adamant they're not going
to deal with the gov with aberdeen the
government there um
they said he's just a clone of maliki
the previous prime minister
uh and what we want is partition
we want the same rights as the kurdish
republic which is don't let federal
troops in
we get a percentage of the oil
we keep iraq federalized but essentially
breaking it up
they want to take baghdad leave the
sunni suburbs go to the sunni region
baghdad itself be an open city kirk kook
is the big oil city in the north will be
divided between the kurds
but there's nobody
in washington wants to hear the word
partition it's it's like
we'd admit we lost the war
it seems to me that
everyone has forgotten that iraq was not
a country
like in
at the time of the first world war that
it was created no it's a sykes pico 1916
the borders are all artificial
and you know we're going to hold them
together with the air force or you know
with drones um but no one wants to admit
it
no one wants to admit that iran has
essentially picked up a country
the new defense minister ubaidi is
was approved by the iranians i just know
this for a fact
the iranian
militias are moving into al-anbar as we
speak now
uh you know
qasim sulaimani from the kutz force is
is on the ground in uniform
it just no one wants to admit we lost
we lost iraq basically we lost the war
and the democrats don't neither the
republicans
i you know i would just say i would say
partition it
or at least stand out of the way but
what the problem is if we become
identified with the iranians then we've
taken sides in the civil war which goes
back to the 7th century
and frankly i've spent a lot of time in
the middle east it's very hard for me to
tell the difference between a shia and a
sunni i mean they all look alike and
they
you know you think well if your name's
ali you've got to be a shia well it's
not true because there's a lot of sunnis
named ali so just the deeper you get
into it the more confusing and you know
you ask people is it really worth
you know
killing yourself over these small
doctrinal changes and apparently it is
next question over here on your right
how do you propose we fight this
asymmetric war or do we just not fight
it and let them take care of it
themselves to the best as possible and
clean up the mess afterwards
i the asymmetrical warfare jeez you know
like what do you do about syria i mean
i mean the fact is it's not so
asymmetrical anymore in the sense that
there's a country there's a sunni
islamic
caliphate or whatever you want to call
it that goes from
aleppo to to mosul
do you
i would i would start i would do it
covertly
i would go back to the partition i would
start sending
arms to the sunnis who disagree with
this but at the end of the day
what's going to destroy
jihad is is other muslims
they're going to look it's unsustainable
the islamic republic cannot govern
indefinitely
it's too violent it's too irrational
there's too many foreigners
from north africa and africa and even
even the west
that
these movements have grown up in islam
before and you see the community turn on
them
it's really an internal problem which
will probably have to be solved
internally and i think at the end of the
day if we're using
bombing we're just going to postpone
that
is there any way to get a hold of it as
as long as the saudis are there in the
foreign well i mean you know we're
talking about a coalition with the
saudis but they're just dumping money
and isis
and they're saying well you guys have
given iraq to the iranians so what else
are we going to do i was always you
can't do that you know so and the
gutteries uh are dumping money and so
are the turks they all are
so they're they're fighting these proxy
wars so we're fighting everybody i mean
we don't want to ally with iran that's
the last thing this president wants to
do is to have anything to do with that
but he's been forced and we've been
forced into that corner
and the and the farther we go you know
more we support iran the more the saudis
are going to send money and there's no
way to stop it
i mean and they're not exactly rational
either i'm not
i'm not their best friend i wrote a book
about saudi arabia sleeping with the
devil and if you ever go to riyadh and
you carry it in your hand i guarantee
you'll be arrested at the airport
so
you know
there are no good guys in the in this in
this conflict
we have another question in the front
um you've alluded to this before this
idea that the cia has become
increasingly militarized over the past 5
10 15 years i'm wondering if you see at
any point in the future
a shift back to the cia becoming more of
a human intelligence
center once again and finally if you
have any advice for an aspiring case
officer
um
i you know i i i tell people i would go
back into the cia in a heartbeat just
simply to understand
our national security establishment but
it's one of those questions
smart enough to get in wise enough to
get out you know spend four or five
years
i think it'll go back and it's and i
tend to for public audiences paint the
worst picture they're a lot of people
doing good work there
and they're they're islands of
excellence and you get into the cia you
stick with those islands and you stay
out of the drone or counter terrorism or
anything that's politically tainted in
washington you don't want to go near
uh which is a big part of the world but
nonetheless there are other things you
can do there and it's um
but i was just at the directorate of
national intelligence's new headquarters
which is right next to the new
counterterrorism center for the fbi and
the cia and everyone else which is right
next to the
agency's headquarters
and it's a new there's a vast expansion
just of physical facilities
state-of-the-art
which interestingly enough when i was
allowed in to
to meet with a group of people there
were little signs up in the hallway
saying
uh
be aware journalist in building yeah or
some i like it especially when
somebody uncleared a red light starts
flashing
again no it's come on it's it's sort of
a joke it's it's like but a lot of it
seems like a joke
well it's huge have you seen that have
you seen the stores in washington yeah
they they are much more luxurious than
fifth avenue or beverly hills or
anywhere
i mean there's more money flowing to
that city than ever in american history
and you know getting into flowing into
the intelligence apparatus of the city
80 billion dollars and the contractors
you know i mean you talk you you listen
to snowden for instance who did he work
for booz allen
all right let me let me pick on snowden
for a little bit okay
he didn't graduate from high school and
he was making a quarter million a year
right
he had a pole dancer too as a girlfriend
i would never have one of those but i
mean it's just it's amazing that you can
work for booz allen and make quarter
million because you can quadruple that
and booz allen was getting a million
for that contract right
so
and that's where all the
counter-terrorism people go they go to
booz allen they retire they go there and
he had been he had been fired from the
cia he was doing white hacks in geneva
apparently where he was saying look i'm
going to show you how your system's
broken but you can't do that in cia
computers
and so but rather than tell the national
security agency what he had done because
they want to get rid of them they just
let them hire them
i mean i know you know snowden has done
some good
throwing a light on this but on the
other hand
when you're in the government you don't
get to decide what you're going to
expose i mean when i write my books even
today
i send them to the cia and they have
dumb comments and some are good and they
take out what's classified they think
it's classified and it's a process but
it's
you know i i can't i can't
go out and to say i'm going to tell you
everything i know
um expose assets you know agents or
you know codes or the rest you just you
can't do that on an individual basis
that's what you're supposed to have
congress for but if congress isn't doing
their job that's another question
next question on your left
um so good segway
um early on you uh
talked about your security security
clearance and you've just kind of
touched upon that process again
so i work for a
organization where i have the above top
secret where i have to go through the
renewal for the security clearance every
five years and it's
a very interesting process as you know
so
you had touched upon that there could be
some conflict between your day-to-day
work
and the security clearance process
they're not totally aligned so i was
wondering if you wanted to come on
on that a little bit more well i i think
the problem with the system is
top secret security clearances um the
cia what it should be in my
humble view
is
it should be sending people out abroad
that really grasp local
local cultures and countries and the
mentality of it and to do that you you
pretty much have to go native in a large
sense you can't lock yourself up in an
embassy
or in any facility and understand what's
going on
now i understand why people with top
secret security clearances that really
know stuff they don't want them
you know going to lebanon and moving
into the bekah valley and you know and
learning
becca arabic or whatever you do or
dealing with drug dealers
or the rest of it i mean
one of the greatest liberating things
for me was leaving the cia and just
going and meeting people i mean it's
like my vision completely open but once
you're in that system
you don't want to have friends out there
you can't have journalist friends you
you can't anybody who's got a criminal
record or the mafia
you can't talk to them unless it's in a
in a certain environment so you're you
by force of these security clearances
you you
you really do limit yourself and limit
your vision
which is not good for
a cia case officer i don't think and so
which what i would do and this is over
simplistic is simply bring people in
where they go up to the secret level
um they see certain stuff but they can't
really expose stuff and they could still
do their jobs
it's amazing by the way journalists
you know that the secrets that leak out
i know more about the cia today
about
you know scandals and the rest of it
than when i was in because the
journalists i mean they're just tough
people talking to journalists i mean i
know
i know people are transferred these are
undercover people what they do what they
did in their last assignment were they a
fake case or not they're just like
it's like i never used to hear that
stuff when i was in
so it's better to be out oh it's much
better you just you know show up and
well a senior counter intelligence
person that i know when he left
the government retired but actually got
hired back in a contract level but
he said to me you know the people out
here are a lot smarter than the people
inside
oh it's it's true i mean well you're
just
it's it's an unfortunate system and the
kgb suffered the same thing you know
this this this inbreeding and
uh washington is a bubble because people
stay there and a top secret security
clearance
once you once you when you're in or when
when you've is a commodity and there's a
price on it there's actually a market
that what it's worth and you can walk
into a job oh you got a ts clearance
here you can have this job um
whether you're qualified or not
and people don't want to don't want to
lose that so
they tend to stay in that area
question down here in front
in one of your books uh
you spoke about the iranians and uh
patients
so ken with that of the background can
you speak about the leadership of the
iranian people and their nuclear
ambitions
well i have a lot of respect for
the iranians in the sense that
they did go to war with the united
states
after the revolution after 1980.
um
they did they took over their embassy
they were responsible for the marines
they were responsible for lockerbie
just just a fact
maybe with the libyans
they
went through this revolutionary period
and the same people that got through it
have now
moved into this thermador
where they they understand us they
understand how far we're going to go you
know there's negotiations are going on
in oman now
they know how far they can go on on
pushing us
so we won't react they also um have
learned to deal with sanctions
they're evading the sanctions through
iraq through banking oil and the rest of
it
i wrote a book about iran as written
about six years ago called the devil we
know um about how one day we would end
up effectively allying with iran people
laughed at me the time i wrote the book
which is what we've done
which which has served their
purposes
i had lunch today with iranian
he said look at if you look at the
borders you include lebanon and syria
and
and iraq and you know and the rest of it
and it looks or even yemen is a sort of
a shia city
the safavid borders they're almost
establishing them and this is
a country we thought was gonna wasn't
gonna make it under it was good collapse
under its own irrationality
and so i find them very pragmatic i went
there in 2005. just after i wrote my
book and um
ex-cia officer landed the airport they
let me in it was with an irish film crew
for british television
let me go anywhere
homey's tomb on quorum sharday
they let me interview the chief of staff
it was really awesome and just
because they understood
their paranoia
well they are paranoid but it's not to
the point where they thought that i was
a threat
so i i
it's a country of 70 million people it's
survived a long time
it's going to survive a lot longer than
these arab countries
by the way when you see these rogue
operations like new york the new york
times article on sunday or bobby
levinson the fbi uh former fbi agent
who's incarcerated in iran
what are you thinking what's going on
nobody seems to know what's going on
in the intelligence community
well what what happened with tom mchale
was he was a
port authority detective
in new york in new york um lived in new
jersey
and
he he befriended a family called the
riggies which are beluch that live in
in iran and they are
by our definition terrorist group so he
was reporting on them and go see the
family members in pakistan
and was talking about attacks that were
going to occur in iran
i thought i mean he was doing his job
monitoring his people i mean it was not
his responsibility
to say hey there's going to be an attack
in a week and decide whether we were
going to tell the iranians or not and
where it was going to occur
that's a political decision
you know it it's unfortunate now because
the iranians are going to react very
badly to this
he may be doing that but apparently
there was no centralization of control
over him or what he was doing
and the same thing with levinson who's
been incarcerated now for a number of
years he was detailed by the directorate
of intelligence just the people you were
talking about and when his contract
expired they said go and we'll pay you
later and they he had all the emails
this is an fbi agent he was kidnapped he
was arrested at quiche
uh i think they found these emails from
the cia on his email on his on his phone
or his computer
uh what my he was probably
roughed up and died of a heart attack is
and this is all speculation
it's incompetence i mean that's not the
way you run intelligence i mean you
don't you don't run intelligence with a
port authority detective
who's you know operating on his own and
you don't let analysts
send messages on email from the cia it's
just it's just sheer incompetence it's
this sprawling intelligence community
which is attic which is out of control
i think so we're out of time for
questions but bob will be signing in the
atrium and you can ask more questions
there thank you very much
[Applause]
you're watching book tv
television for serious readers